well it happened on May 19th 2019 HBO
celebrated fantasy series Game of
Thrones officially came to an end
meanwhile the series of novels it's
based upon is far from complete as
you're no doubt aware author george RR
martin has yet to finish the final two
books in his epic saga a Song of Ice and
Fire right now the winds of winter and a
dream of spring are still very much
works in progress
however Martin made some rather
interesting comments regarding the end
of the book series and how it will
ultimately compare to the finale of the
HBO show but before we get into that
please note spoilers ahead I'll tell you
everything on May 20th Martin shared a
post on his personal website that began
on a rather sentimental note writing the
last night the last show it's hard to
believe it is over if truth be told
elsewhere he expressed gratitude to
series creators David Benioff and DB
Weiss offering thanks to everyone who
helped make the HBO show a reality it
has been a wild ride to say the least
there were 42 cast members at the season
8 premiere in New York City and that
wasn't even all of them and the crew
though less visible than the cast were
no less important then he offered a
characteristically vague progress report
assuring fans said he's still hard at
work on finishing the books let me say
this much last night was an ending but
it was also a beginning nobody is
retiring anytime soon and I'm writing
winter is coming
I told you long ago and so it is in
while he didn't commit to any firm dates
writing the winds of winter is very late
I know I know but it will be done I
won't say when I've tried that before
only to burn you all and jinx myself but
I will finish it and then we'll come a
dream of spring but here's the burning
question will a dream of spring have the
same conclusion as the show instead of a
direct answer Martin with the cryptic
route writing well yes and no and yes
and no and yes and no and yes
well at least Martin has a theory as to
why the books will inevitably differ
from the HBO series I am working in a
very different medium than David and Dan
never forget he's got a point where
Benioff and Weiss wrapped up the final
season in six episodes Martin's last two
novels in the book series are expected
to span quote 3,000 manuscript pages as
he sagely notes there are characters who
never made it onto the screen at all and
others who died in the show but still
live in the books so if that's going to
impact the end of the book series which
endings should be considered the real
one
Martin clearly thinks that's a silly
question asking an evasive rhetorical
question responds how many children did
Scarlet O'Hara have well take the base
and answer that for you she has three
children in the 1936 novel Gone with the
Wind one child in the 1939 film based on
the book and nun in real life because
she's not a real person
got it
Martin's post echos some of his past
remarks about the fundamental
differences between the HBO series and
the novels back in April he told Rolling
Stone would I prefer Benioff and Weiss
do it exactly the way I did it sure it's
two variations of the same story or a
similar story and you get that whenever
anything is adapted when all is said and
done perhaps the biggest takeaway from
Martin's post comes from how he decided
to sign off how about this I'll write it
you read it then everyone can make up
their own mind and argue about it on the
Internet
sounds like a plan in the meantime who
do you think will prove a faster writer
george RR martin or Brienne of Tarth
[Music]
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
Game of Thrones are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]